[Musique]
et si on te demande comment tu es venu
en métro en passant par quelle station
salazar et ensuite porte de champerret
je vais tout déchirer j'espère bien
enfin pas tout quand même
[Musique]
le diagnostic c'est quoi c'est un
autisme particulièrement sévère j'ai eu
l'assistante sociale et les mineurs elle
demandant le placement judiciaire ça
laisse quand même dangereux environ
quinze jours
je trouve une solution j avais de dire à
tout le monde je vais trouver une
solution tous ceux qui seront placés les
inspecteurs les gars c'est ce que c'est
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales
c'est dans le viseur vous avez pris des
initiatives qui pose des questions nous
avons à charge de revenir à une
situation qui donne plus de sécurité
cette association répond aux besoins
chance à l'accepter patients que la
société refuse ou qui semblent
impossibles à améliorer
m
pour moi je vais vous dire il ya ceux
qui vous regardent plutôt ce qui vous
est peu plus pierre les autres
et croyez moi que son talent book pro
depuis 15 ans les médecins les hôpitaux
appellent tous les jours sur mon
portable pour savoir si on peut appeler
encore d'autres enfants
tu dépenses pour d'argent c'est bien
trop bon
c'est à vous qu'on se raccrocher
son petit plus mais vous connaissez
beaucoup diplôme qui prépare à se venger
de droite toute la journée
tu la connais c'est la fermeture
ce que je peux peut-être contre ton
épaule
[Musique]